we're here in III 2016 I'm Justin this
is Peter and we just got done playing
some legend of zelda breath of the wild
that completely different take on the
Zelda franchise Peter what were your
immediate impressions of this I mean I
was immediately under the impression
that I was playing a modern sort of
reimagining of the original Legend of
Zelda right that game opened up you
there was some like text kind of telling
you what your goal was what was
happening in the world but really you
were left on your own to sort of start
your adventure and figure out where
you're gonna go what you're gonna do
that persists in this game and I really
appreciated that but there's so much to
do in the world that doesn't really
compare to any other Zelda game going
through the demo it really opened up how
freeing that is that you can gonna go on
a path and I was doing the demo on my
god the person who was leading he was
like if you go along this way you know
you'll be able to go to a dungeon and
get a fuel for what's going on and I
just kind of went off into the woods I
started chopping down a tree and like
trying to get some fruit it's like you
can just do so many weird little things
yeah you can chop down trees you can
gather wood you can build fires you can
collect ingredients you can combine
those ingredients and cook to make
health items or elixirs that give you
like greater speed or stronger you know
attacks or a better defense or even able
to sneak we know with more efficiency at
night it's a super impressive either way
you can fight an enemy and they can drop
their weapon mid-fight and that just
becomes your weapon if you want it you
can use it in that fight you can store
it for later and it's just amazing like
how we're source file you can be in this
world and it feels like a much more
organic experience on so many levels
compared to you know some of the more
popular Zelda games of the past five
years it's taking the Zelda franchise in
a completely new direction and they're
adding things that you definitely don't
associate with the Zelda franchise of
course there's the master sword and
there's link in the the color palette
all evokes that nostalgic feeling but
when you're fighting an enemy and your
weapon can break like that's never been
in a Zelda game you can you have to pick
up weapons from enemies it you don't
feel as attached to I have this one
thing and I'm going to keep using it
you've read you want to be more
experimental with how you approach
things totally and one thing I really
love this little change is the way that
they handle bombs now and the past bombs
would be items you would have to collect
and you could run out of them right so
now it is more of sort of a a magical
ability that link has and bombs work on
a cooldown timer so after you throw one
you have to wait but more
that you can throw a bomb and a remote
detonate it like that's how it works so
you throw a bomb and then you just push
your hand out it explodes in this huge
or bits it's a link that we've never
seen before with these kind of abilities
and the biggest ability I think the
thing that you can't not mention when
you see this game is that link can
finally jump he can jump and he can
climb like he can climb anything like
that I know that like it seems so silly
when you think about like oh all sorts
of games let you'd run and jump and do
all these things but Zelda has kind of
built itself on outside of the I think
Link's Awakening we had a feather year
of course you're able to jump there but
the 3d games have always been about
building puzzles and building a world
where that happens automatically and
giving you that freedom opens up whole
new venues to explore the levels the
world that we were playing around in had
so much verticality and so much to it it
did yeah and one of the important things
about that is verticality is meant to
sort of give you a means to get from
point A to point B and to spot things in
the environment that you wouldn't see
from the ground level a lot of these
dungeons are sort of held in these
towers and from the top of the tower
which also access for like a checkpoint
like we can go back after you die you
can spot things in the environment and
then use a sort of a hang glider to get
there you wouldn't see it if you were
down below and that opens up a lot of
interesting possibilities but even dying
itself sounds like part of the fun like
your men to experiment you're meant to
go out of your way to see what you're
capable of to take the risk to try to
like get some reward out of it be at the
experience there like a new weapon or
anything but when you don't you just go
back to you know pretty much the closest
area that you were and it doesn't take
that long it seems to sort of get back
to the last place that you were you know
experimenting but the map that we played
on and they say it was only one percent
of the game one person of the game the
game is about 12 times the size of
twilight princess which is already a
huge game one of the biggest zelda games
up to that point yeah like they showed
us the map that we were playing on ahead
hyrule castle it had the Temple of Time
Temple of Time Hyrule River like oh good
was the death mountain on their death
mount you could see death mountain in
the distance all these recognizable
features and then they pulled the map
back and it's like wait that is like
this much of a map this big I I have no
idea what to expect from the rest of
that world and they did say that the
stuff that we were playing the
opportunities around you were perhaps
more dense than they will be in the rest
of the map and that was because that's
in the game introducing you these
possibilities but likewise we didn't
really have a
horse right and no having horses one of
the important things in this game so
down the road even if things are more
spread out it sounds like you'll be able
to get from point A to point B in
effectively just the same amount of time
to experience all of that stuff yeah
it's it gives us Zelda in a way that
I've never played it before and it's not
what I was expecting but it's still so
exciting to think about those
possibilities like even one hour with
the game felt like nowhere near enough
and I can't I don't think I'm gonna have
enough time before the game even comes
out to feel like I understand everything
you can do in this world there's a lot
that you can do it's really impressive
and like there's there's so many things
in that we've just never seen before
just to keep going back to that because
I keep remembering stuff there's so much
like link has like Knight armor now yet
it's not just it's not just one suit you
get those like the red red armor blue
armor serene armor right you can
actually get different clothes you get a
whole suit of armor that's amazing like
and it's so different for Zelda it's
like so taking things in a new fun
exciting direction yeah and there's even
like a whole lot temperature system now
right so if link is getting colder he's
too hot he can actually change his
clothing to counteract that which is
pretty interesting on a stealth mechanic
of like South has always had like a
little bit of a part of Zelda but that's
actually something that you do in this
game you could crawl around in the grass
you can see how much noise you're making
and that plays into how you can approach
battles and how you how you're gonna
fight the guys you're going up against
yeah and I rule itself has been
transformed quite a bit because the the
story goes that link has sort of been in
hibernation for a century because a
hundred years ago gannon overtook hyrule
castle i should say he's referred to as
calamity Gannon he doesn't really seem
to be like a being as much as an entity
in this game but so now that he's on the
verge of taking over all of Hyrule
you've woken up and you and you know you
have to explore Hyrule and ruin we
didn't see any villages of people we saw
buildings that had overgrowth all over
them you know things look like they
hadn't been touched by humans in a
century at this very familiar setting
like I'm sure that because there was
just one percent of the matter aren't
gonna be villages yet people i expect
that might happen dungeons and bosses
and like all these things that we don't
even know what those are like yet like
that's so exciting that we're still get
to experience it well and recently
linked it has always been introduced as
sort of a member of a village right he
plays some sort of role in that and is
like graduating from something like an
Skyward Sword or you know he's just sort
of setting out on an adventure from his
hometown and here you know we're
introduced to him he's waking up in a
cave he walks outside there's very
little direction there's a young female
voice you could safely assume it's the
princess zelda i think but she's kind of
guiding him out of the cave from there
on it's it's really just this massive
open world thank you are the light our
light at must shine upon Hyrule once
again now go you do meet an old man sort
of strange old man in the mountain who
provides you some information about his
past but not very much but he wants to
ask you about who you are and when you
start on your journey you sort of
encounter an opportunity to interact
with another character and he starts to
ask you details about that and you can
choose whether or not to tell him which
in a sense is whether or not to trust
him and I have a hunch that he's gonna
play a pivotal role as a bad guy maybe
it's Stoke said that it's sort of
interesting and another thing really
interesting that the zelda game does is
it gives you a different paths kind of
related to what you said at the
beginning that you don't have to go on a
set path for as far as dungeons if you
want to go and get one ability first or
go get bombs first you're not tethered
to approaching things always in the same
path it's not a very linear level 1
level 2 level 3 it's it's a world to
explore yeah and you know when I asked
him as well like ok people plays all the
games they can collect every item
usually you know within a reasonable
amount of time and feel like they've
beaten the game but this world is so big
compared to other Zelda games how long
will it take people to collect all these
items could they play for a hundred
hours he didn't say yes or no to 100
hours but he said no one in the office
has found every item I have no idea
who's gonna be able to do it you know
we're gonna have a lot of gameplay up on
the site for people to watch there's a
whole stream here at e3 and we're gonna
be having as many editors as we can't
get hands on with this and try about try
it out and see what else they can
discern from this demo but if you want
to read more and see more of The Legend
of Zelda breadth of the while well you
can find out right here on gamespot com
you